that's right I've seen the Magic Mike
movies and I enjoy them and they say all
we cover here is comic book related
movies or geek franchises well not today
the day we're talking about Magic Mike's
last dance with director Steven
Soderbergh who helmed the first movie
returning to close out the sexiest
Trilogy that ever existed so guys please
go ahead leave a like it's the most
seductive thing you can do let's see
what's going on in the Last Dance
trailer
[Music]
what did you want before Miami
sell Furniture something everything
I just wanted to escape my life
Salma Hayek
do you like bartending it's not really
what I do what is it that you really do
oh you sure you show her you came along
and gave me these unexpected
magical moment oh yeah
[Music]
wow just these two famous people dancing
with each other
normally he sleeps with them at the end
with this famous theater
disconnected we're gonna wake them up
with a wave of passion they've never
felt before
hell yeah
all right the missionary artist magic
mine
the real question is why for you no
one's believed in your mom is
so what's the show about it's the same
more will she marry For Love or Money so
what does she pick
Ed I hope you pick love why does she
feel like she has to choose
it sounds to me it's using to let go
he'd have both I guess yeah and some
good
[Music]
maybe that as well
oh I know what I'm doing this
Valentine's Day
you're not shutting me down not this
time you're so good at this
I'm not gonna just let us give up
every woman that walks into this theater
feel that a woman can have whatever she
wants whatever she wants
last night I know you you were a cop
right did you arrested what's your name
Kim
let you up for the warning right
interesting interesting okay that's
funny because this has like a rom-com
Vibe like I'm I I get why if they
release it on Valentine's Day because
remember the first I mean they've all
had a romantic angle in every one of
them you know what's funny is the last
movie had both Amber Heard and Jada
Pinkett Smith
foreign
you want into that as you will it's just
I just find it kind of funny that
they're they're both in it anyway guys
this this will be
what's what's funny to me is I remember
the first movie having more emotion a
little bit more heart and feels than one
might expect out of the Magic Mike
franchise when you see the trailer it's
just gonna be like hootering and
hollering and guys dancing on Sexy and
then you're like wow Matthew
McConaughey's phenomenal in this movie
and and the movie itself just had a
little bit more Soul than expected then
they did Magic Mike double XL now keep
in mind I've only seen these movies like
once when they the year they first came
out so my memory on specifics is is just
not that clear but I I remember my
feeling being like oh this this sequel
is more like what I thought the first
one might be which is just a really kind
of fun movie and it loses a good amount
of its nuance and depth that it's that
the first one was aiming for and it was
even sober to not direct that one but it
was still a fun movie like regardless it
was still fun and it had it had enough
heart you know and then this one uh I'm
not sure I guess if it sure sort of fits
part of the fun though is is the rest of
the Ensemble of the people because yeah
obviously Mike is is the main character
but there's two actors whose last names
I never know how to pronounce correctly
Joe meganella Joe Jello Joe manganello
and uh Matt Matt Bomer I want to say is
his name I think they're like wonderful
additions to the mic Magic Mike
franchise I feel like they're they're
such an integral ingredients this one
I've never seen the Step Up movies
but this kind of looks like the step up
trailers for those movies I haven't seen
those films but this feels more akin to
that than it does to Magic Mike just a
little bit more body is being shown in
in the trailers and uh if I'm not
mistaken Magic Mike is a pretty big is
it a Vegas show or Broadway show
something like that it seems like it's
taking some more of that inspiration of
that I like the idea of like though they
the people are attending what looks like
a classical theater show but oh man
everyone's getting like super turned on
by this thing where it's it's
performance art it's the stage where
normally you wouldn't associate it with
something this incredibly passionate and
seductive but then here we are where you
got attendees it doesn't look like the
crowd is going to be filled with you
know like the the crowds that the first
two movies are filled with or the crowds
that you sort of expect when you go
watch a Magic Mike movie on opening
night a bunch of women who didn't
hollering that's part of the fun of the
Magic Mike experience I I don't get the
vibe this is that kind of movie like I
don't I don't see this being that film
where it is a bunch of women like it's a
fun part of the experience it's a fun
part of the craft uh this looks like it
is designed to be like yeah my
girlfriend wants to go see it my wife
wants to go see it to be it'd be kind of
fun it looks a little bit more romantic
because you know don't get it wrong man
uh it's kind of crazy to see Salma Hayek
in this role and you know like one of
the things I saw when I was a kid was
her a famous sexy dance scene in uh From
Dusk Till Dawn never left my Noggin her
and Channing Tatum just being all over
each other I'm drawn to it why not
they're too hot ass
celebrities so sure I'll go check it out
I mean this I'm not really sure what
they're going for here because the the
way the plot looks it looks like such a
like by the Numbers type of plot like it
doesn't feel like it's anything that
different in terms of the genre that
it's now going into it like with the
dance movie romantic comedy even when
like you can't threaten me to lose the
theater then they're gonna have some big
finale Showdown like it looks looks
pretty simple and looks pretty basic and
maybe that's all it really requires they
didn't really show us anything from the
dance numbers that looks entirely
different I thought the last one ended
in a way where yeah I could see this
being the last movie but I'm always down
for more Magic Mike why not since
Channing Tatum he's great at what he
does and looks like he can still move
like nobody's business just curious to
see why Steven Soderberg specifically
was like yeah this is the one I'm gonna
return for I'm going to return for the
third installment because I have
something that I I want to do for this
film that is is going to stand out and
be different from the last ones because
yeah it does look different but what
about it looks unique that's sort of my
question it does feel more like a
typical dance movie but hey
still still looks more classy you know
and I don't know I just want to be in a
theater with a bunch of single women who
didn't hollering that's what I want
they're the fun ones but anyway guys uh
what did you think about this trailer
the film looks okay it looks all right
I'm sure it's gonna be more enjoyable
than how this trailer actually felt to
me and uh it has more of that like
Broadway vibe to it which is interesting
leave your thoughts down below go ahead
subscribe leave a like last but not
least listen to the pic
Michael B Omni media he's joining me for
a movie reaction this week we did
Coraline don't think I forgot Michael
you have a dancing background when your
channel is suddenly really tanking I
hope to see you go down a path where you
reignite
them sexy dance skills you know what I
need to have a bachelor party I'm
expecting you know I'm gonna hire you to
be the dancer it's gonna be great get
all my friends here
you're like yeah guys oh we got
something going we got something sexy
girl and you show up and with your
beanie and your long hair and your
glasses it's just like hey guys I'm here
to be your stripper today it's gonna be
so funny he has no Omni media you it's
it's only really funny if you know what
he looks and sounds like or he's gonna
like a guy node no I don't mean that
it's just this Demeter would just not be
the presents you'd expect anyway Michael
looking forward to seeing if people like
your reaction with me and with Coraline
but uh you're doing a good job and
thanks for being part of our patreon
page for so long
[Music]